[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis né joseph in con je suis
designer chez vraiment vraiment et
s'agit d'une agence de design d'intérêt
général c'est en france et en belgique
on est une équipe pluridisciplinaire
c'est à dire que on a à la fois des
profils de designers d'architectes de
graphistes et d'urbanistes mais aussi
des profils de chercheurs et analystes
nos projets en fait porte sur les lieux
les parcours et les futurs de l'action
publique
le piano a missionné pour être
activateur de territoire dans les
contextes d'urbanisme transitoire
d'urbanisme de transitoire c'est une
façon un peu inédite de penser et de
fabriquer la ville en se donnant le
droit à l'erreur
et c'est pas conventionnel dans les
pratiques d'aménagement de territoire
on va venir avaient des dispositifs et
des actions qui sont qui seront
temporaires aux réversible pour venir en
fait tester certains usages de nouveaux
usages
l'implication des acteurs locaux et des
usagers dans les différents processus
donc soit de conception de construction
et programmation c'est la clé de
réussite des actions qu'on va mener
parce qu'en fait en notre rôle en tant
qu à des activateurs c'est vraiment de
capitaliser sur des initiatives locales
existantes et de les aider à décoller
aujourd'hui on est dans une phase de
diagnostic dans laquelle nous arpentons
le territoire de la zac de moulon à la
zac de polytechnique à peu près et on va
à la rencontre des étudiants mais aussi
des familles qui sont fraîchement
installé mais aussi des salariés des
commerçants et
ouvriers et afin de se saisir des enjeux
et des problématiques du terrain qui
nous permettront ensuite de proposer un
programme d'action pertinent quittera
mis en place à partir du mois de
septembre
en parallèle de ce programme d'action on
va aussi développer du mobilier qui
viendra soutenir ce programme est aussi
un concept de signalétique avec ce
projet on cherche à rassembler les
usagers du plateau qui vivent sur le
plateau qui vous pourrait
potentiellement devenir de la vallée
mais qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas de raison
de se croiser et ce afin de pouvoir
développer un sentiment d'appartenance
au territoire est aussi l appropriation
des espaces publics qui vont être encore
en chantier pendant plusieurs années